United Airlines is taking a lot of heat
after one of their employees wouldn't
allow two young girls on a flight
because she thought the leggings they
were wearing were inappropriate yeah a
lot of people talking about this the
internet exploded a lot of people are
complaining that that's just how
ten-year-old girls dressed these days
and that United's policy is sexist now
actually I think they may have a point
especially when you consider how United
Airlines dresses their male pilots we
have a few of them tonight
they're here these are the United male
pilots totally a double standard check
it out these guys work for the airline
[Applause]
those are the guys will be flying my dad
and leggings out for Easter
you